I know these tests for me for children  that doesn't mean you don't have to show  me I'm worried that you're not taking  proper care of yourself we've come too  close to losing you too many times  there's a difference in you I'm getting  better calm down I'm right here with you  you're my mother  now you're just being hateful that's  because I hate you  where were you and who were you with I  think I understand what you want I've  seen every version of you you can be  well if you want to  there are three levels one  - if you go beyond the boundary it  straight three would you like to see  what that feels like  I had to be here for you to find me  so check